my name is J Whittaker so I've always
been really interested in passionate
about energy technologies even since
high school and certainly in college
where I worked on photovoltaics which
are solar panels right I did a variety
of I answered a variety of fundamental
materials and physics questions back in
those days and then I went to graduate
school and got my degree in a more sort
of broad materials characterization set
of fields and then I really got into
what I'm into now which is
electrochemical energy storage devices
the common theme to this career path
that I've taken has been focused on
devices and technologies that take
energy in one form and change it to
another form and make it useful for a
variety of different ways so when I came
to see him you I really wanted to do
something different application wise but
similar technology wise with my with my
skills with my background and so I
changed over from very expensive
specific kinds of technologies for
spacecraft to what does what do we need
on this planet what's going to make a
real difference and so one of the
projects I do is large-scale energy
storage for the grid and for off-grid
solar and for developing countries and
so I do a lot of work in that arena I
also do a fair amount of work on things
like do electric vehicles make sense how
to electric vehicles are they too
expensive or not will the batteries last
this is really about the technology
inside these vehicles and it's also
about consumers interest in buying them
so I collaborate with a variety of CMU
folks to understand the meaning of
electrified transportation is it
legitimate and why and I think it's CMU
we pride ourselves in being skeptical
and doing really strong analytical work
to support our our ideas about
conclusions and one of the things that
that's been maybe most prominent of what
I've done here has been the spin-off
company aqueon energy which is a battery
company that is based on an idea that
started here at CMU and it's a water
bits it like a salt water based battery
basically it is sodium ions that
function with a very simple electrodes
carbon and manganese oxide it's a very
simple package it looks cooler like a
box of bread box or whatever there are
two or three main markets that we're
looking at right now for this technology
the first one is off grid or micro grids
these are in developing countries or
places where there's not a really well
developed electrical grid or the grid is
in some way or another not that reliable
the other application is much larger and
it's going to take a bit longer for us
to be big enough to make things that are
big enough to impact it and that's the
North American power grid and there are
a lot of places where there are pinch
points where for whatever reason moving
electrons around the grid are very
expensive or not possible at the right
times a day and one way to relieve that
is to put a big thing that stores energy
it's a big block black box electrons in
and electrons out and a battery is
certainly one way to do it but we have
to get to the right cost point and the
right price point and we are on a very
good course to be there in a handful of
years